Europe's massive problem of youth
unemployment tops the agenda this week
as ministers responsible for employment
Social Policy health and consumer
affairs meet in Luxembourg with EU
leaders set next week to focus on ways
to get young people into jobs the
ministers will discuss efforts to
implement a youth guarantee scheme seen
as a top EU employment priority on
average across the 27 EU nations almost
one in four people under 25 were out of
work in April the youth guarantee aims
to ensure that young people like them
receive a quality job offer further
education and apprenticeship or
traineeship within four months of
leaving school or becoming unemployed
youth unemployment will also be in the
spotlight as the ministers try to agree
a general approach on the European
globalisation adjustment fund the EGF so
that negotiations can begin with the
European Parliament's the fun was set up
in response to the economic crisis and
helps workers who lost their jobs due to
the recession and globalization to find
new employment and develop new skills
The ministers will debate the scope of
the fund ways to finance it categories
of people who might be eligible and
support for youth employment the
conditions of those most in need will
also be on the agenda as the council
hears a progress report on the fund for
European aid to the most deprived EU
leaders confirmed in February that 2.5
billion euros was earmarked for this
group to the 2014-2020 period debate
will focus on a mechanism for member
states to participate some countries
have reservations about whether an EU
level fund covering all 27 nations is
the best way to help and differ over the
form that the scheme should take